a car was moved on taking on another
lucky member mr. bata blinks beta blinks
is playing against the highest rated
player he will probably ever get a
chance to play against that that's true
and this is position where white just
has a little bit of an edge based on the
space advantage he'll play b3 here
that's exactly what he did
the C file will be a big determining
factor as well again commodities what do
we learn here today so now white wants
to find a way to to improve playing the
Queen's that I was going to suggest a
for first but Queen before is probably
even better by a car Oh a four and a
five and Queen B four and then try to
use the C file and these positions are
deceptively terrible okay I'm actually
going to show tell you guys something
cuz I've lost games like this as black
playing against stronger grandmasters
where you feel like you've done
something because you've maintained
complete equality in terms of the
structure and you don't seem to have any
obvious positional weaknesses of first
glance and then one move like Queen
before comes in and you realize you're
just completely lost literally black has
no moves if he moves the knight he's
losing the pawn he has no way to
challenge the C file and this position
is literally even before ninety seven
probably just lost for black like now
resign able lost but lost against good
players and and it's a good lesson
because you can't evaluate the position
as just equal because the static
weaknesses are are equal like meaning
it's static equality this structure is
is symmetrical or there's only one or
two open files because what ends up
being highlighted in those positions is
that the first person to get the
initiative the first person to execute
tactics on the open files and diagonals
ends up running away with it it's like
it's like a it's like a train a snowball
effect because it's not dynamic and
because you don't have something else
that you can play for to kind of make up
for the weaknesses you have so anyway
it's a good lesson rook takes d7 here as
possible no although I would love to
take and then sack the Queen and then
take E 5 and play Bishop d4 that would
have been that would have been funsies
but again that's why he's better than me
so it's a good lesson to see that back
in this position
here black is in big trouble despite the
seemingly equality like I said they're
deceptively terrible would really love
if people in the the general chat
following the game would calm down too
many trolls too many people going crazy
everyone let's just calm down
no spamming please no one's a troll
we're all wonderful wonderful people but
don't act like one please
okay this position is just painful for
mr. bata blinks and we learned something
valuable I remember the first time I
lost a game exactly like that thinking I
had held my own against a really strong
player and just all the sudden feeling
like I got strangled
so Bishop d4 check is coming here and
with it a little bit of a checkmate
maybe now I guess the bishop will just
be better than the knight in the end
game multiple ways to win this is the
easiest by the way it's a double attack
also threatening rook f6 check and mr.
beta blinks resigns I'm trying to play
Hikaru just to have one game here live
TV we'll see if he accepts since I know
everyone was happy about that idea
sounded kind of fun to watch me get
totally rocked and try to talk about my
thought process we will see if he
recognizes my challenge I just sent a
card challenge
and no not quite accepts the challenge
from candidate master storm giant 58
should be fun as well okay another a yo
handz number 2 number 2 right
they call me number 2 this is pretty
typical stuff a modern approach here not
the most dangerous move order from white
but it transposes into a pretty standard
approach white wants the rook on c1 and
the point is he anticipates the pawn
structure to change where white might
get a three-on-two majority on the Queen
side and so white tries to position the
pieces in that way but this is usually
not the best transition because now the
D pawn is weak black is going to play 97
and 9f5 and maybe even Queen f6 in some
positions so after Knight f5 white might
have to play 92 and then in some
positions a 5 comes in so white doesn't
actually want the 3 on 2 structure in a
way that creates a pan off pot pan off
structure that's this is the pan off
structure so normally that sounds good
for white when you think pan off because
the pan off implies this 3 on 2 which if
you took all the pieces off the board
right now White's pawn structure is just
winning structurally just completely
winning because White has this winning
three on two but the problem is you
can't just take all the pieces off the
board and and before that can happen the
D pawn is a target and black is going to
mobilize to try to get e5 and open up
the center in this case he doesn't need
to because he wins the pawn if he hadn't
and that's what he would have tried to
do so you have to be careful
overextending the Queen side against the
Alekhine's and some variations of the
caro-kann this is sort of how I can get
in trouble by advancing over advancing
on the Queen side the bishop comes back
and what's going to happen here the rook
ending definitely leaves black with some
winning chances I is a5 I was going to
say but maybe not the best though in
this case I think he's going to actually
end up winning three pawns for two I
think black will end up actually with
with a five on three here but these
pawns being isolated he's going to find
a way to pick up this pawn and this pawn
in exchange for this pawn and in doing
so you just have a completely winning
endgame and storm giant actually doesn't
even really prevent this so now it's
going to get real ugly this is a good
prophylactic with trading off a pair of
rooks which storm giant doesn't even
stop in fact allows it is is definitely
makes your life easier when you're the
one converting a to pawn endgame
advantage it with rooks just FYI because
the one thing your opponent might be
able to do with the Jumbo Brooks is
create threats on the seventh rank or
you know maybe a mating net possibility
on the back rank so a simple trader
Brooks was the easiest way for black to
approach the position and and that's
what he did and his opponent didn't
really stop him water the source of life
okay again I would try it I would try to
play hit karo again we'll see if he
accepts nope not quite mace windu nice
right I mean we all love a good Star
Wars reference next thing we'll be
talking about Captain Kirk joke's on you
you ever notice how frustrated Trekkies
get when you like say like Oh what
episode did Anakin fight Captain Kirk as
if you've mortally wound them to confuse
Star Wars and Star Trek
well then maybe they shouldn't have the
same word to start the show Star Wars to
start the same word alright just because
I'm not a super Trekkie nerd right I
mean when is Bilbo going to get involved
and play with Dumbledore right see what
I did there
totally frustrating all the lotr Harry
Potter nerds I'm just joshing yeah I
love all of you this positions horrible
for black 94 is money why not just 94 94
96 loves it although actually White's
attack is just as good at black it's
Castle doesn't even need to stop it
Queen sack this is going to be awesome
he's going to put the bishop on of six
and then he's going to try to put a
piece on d6 here this is gonna be fun
zzzz hashtag unnecessary by Hikaru
meaning he was completely winning if he
didn't go even if you can go for this
but hashtag awesome
hashtag follow us both on Twitter at
yang mcaro
so even though it was unnecessary this
is just so much fun I mean literally
black can't move the bishop because
after I take I'm going to be mating you
if you don't move the bishop you can't
get the rook into the game on a slow
level I'm threatening plans like Knight
f3 Knight g5 night h7 move the bishop
Knight f6 and just winning I also have
threats of rook d4 so I can get the
knight in here but okay white white says
well I'm sorry black says well I'm going
to give you the pawn but maybe he just
didn't realize he's getting mated I
don't know if the only move is Queen to
c8 it's not really going to get much
better after Queen to c8 there are
multiple ways to win but I think the
easiest might just be Rookie 7 check and
then bring the other night in you should
be a little careful of the Queen coming
to c6 oh no you don't because the knight
guards it this is like anybody ever seen
the game short Timman of course you have
because it's the greatest chess game of
all time where white walks the King up
the board and ends up mating black all
because of the complete domination of
the dark squares in the open file if you
have not seen the game short Timman
somebody quote the year of the game it
was 91 92 it was an Alekhine's defense
opening so you can look up that you have
to you have to review that game but this
is just domination which leads to
confusion here with blacks pieces being
awkwardly coordinated again after Queen
to c8 Knight d5 one thing after Queen c6
is I can actually so he just he just
wins but let's find the win what was the
win right away I didn't see the win
right away although again I'm going to
try to challenge your car again because
I know everyone wants it you can check
and after the King moves then bring the
knight in but then I thought coming to
c6 though I like I said I remember this
guy was guarded and and so we can just
bring the knight in here and bishops
hanging rook saying and so this is a fun
this is a fun time games like this right
sacrificing the Queen of course a car
will recognize what what most of us
would take a lot of calculation to to
have to think but quickly recognize just
how bad this was and look at that a
carro accepts the challenge so just like
that we're going to have some live
commentary everybody all right let's get
the juices flowing
raise the roof here we go I'm going to
do my best not to embarrass myself I
already did it too late so now let's
just have fun
Knight f6 at least it's 3-minute so it's
not bullet okay he's going to play the
Letran pass key which is just never fun
never fun for me to play against I'm not
going to lie to you this should be fun
Z's to play for the mainline Trump off
ski and ok we get this is all pretty
pretty typical stuff I'm going to play
early and often see 5 early and often be
aggressive be EA GG re SS I ve I'm going
to defend the pin and you have to be
careful you don't want the bishop pair
to run wild on you if you're white here
so I'm hoping that I can I can use that
against a car but let's let's go ahead
and just be aggressive let's be let's
have tons of fun in this game here and
get wild with it totally dynamic totally
open I want to play g6 and Fein kettle
the bishop that's actually what I want
to do believe it or not I can take and
play d5 but things will get awkward real
quick I'll play Bishop g7 anyway I think
he'll take on c5 first and if Queen to
d6 I would have played 27 and tried to
trade so I'm gonna go this way which you
know we maintain the tension that's sort
of the goal for me maintaining the
tension somewhat because with the bishop
pair I'm hoping that helps but now now I
don't know what happened here I don't
like it I don't like his ability to to
keep hold of the dark squares and put
the knight on f6 so I don't know how I
handled that maybe I need to slow down a
little bit but it is three-minute he
puts check I mean he gives check and
it's exactly what we would expect I
don't want to take because after take
stakes he played Queen d2 in the h6 pawn
is weak
Bishop e4 looks good but I'll go ahead
and take here and my hope was I could
play Knight a5 and start to get some
counter play on the Queen side
if I can put the night on b3 and then
maybe bring the bishop over the problem
is his attack is getting out of this
world it's getting out of this world
strong if takes takes Queen takes his
Knight takes g6 and he wins he's already
threatening to play Bishop takes g6 so
I'm going to play Bishop to b5 and hope
I'm not just mated right away if Bishop
takes g6 and I take on f1 he decides he
doesn't want to allow it either but my
thought now is maybe I could take on f6
if I take on f6 and then play Queen to
d6 the attack just looks monstrous
monstrous for him and I'd wanted to play
King h7 but okay but now I thought was
oh I thought I had a nice c4 I thought I
had a knight c4 but he is Knight takes
g6 check so I have to do something
awkward rook age three is going to come
from my opponent which doesn't look fun
but maybe I can take up four rook aged
six and then King a g8 and a bishop
check move he has a bunch of discoveries
but does he have a winning discovery I
don't know if he moves the knight my
hope was just to get Knight to c4 and if
I can get counter play quickly if Queen
takes a five is not a threat now I think
is the night because I have Queen takes
d4 check and then I can take on anyone
but if he let's see if he moves the
knight okay he moves the rook but I'm
going to bring the knight in to c4 ASAP
and not let him take I would love to
just take on f4 but he plays Queen h4
and I cannot defend I'm not sure I can
defend anyway okay I'm not sure I can
defend anyway so we're going to do
something weird just because he's not
threatening mate just this second if
we're cage three Queen takes f6 if he
took on d5 I thought maybe I would even
trade Queens but after 90 d5 rook h3 is
still a threat though not immediately I
have to find a way to guard age six or I
can resign
I only have 35 seconds that's a problem
that is a big problem
little China I'm threatening rook b2 now
if I can just keep up the pace and keep
it awkward
keep it awkward keep it weird my motto
for life if I take on d4 he takes on b5
do I have anything I thought I might get
something with Bishop to g4 takes he
moves if I play g4 now what does he have
next I'm not sure I'll do it I'll do it
I wanted the knight to come to e3 but
I'm losing I'm losing the knight on c4
he takes there oh he plays King there
what if I take on g2 with check trick
him to take with the bishop which
doesn't matter and I resigned okay and
the crowd goes wild and the crowd goes
wild and the crowd goes wild the car
takes me down okay well we could play
another one if he wants I'll try to play
another one I think you guys have fun
with this with this approach but he's
got other people to play too and I don't
want to hog up all the time I just you
know you don't get a chance to play a
car that often I told you my nature was
selfish you know who is John Galt here
doing my best
we'll see we'll see what he wants his
last gaming it's mace window now that
was amazing so where did we learn from
my game here right this is an
interesting term posit like you know
nothing too bad for me
probably this early extension of c5 is
overly aggressive of course c5 right
away and b6 Bishop b7 you can play it
sort of like a Tori and OH
here we go again he says okay okay we'll
run this thing back we'll do it again
but we'll see with white if I can do any
damage we will see if I can do any
damage with white we will have a
Sicilian which means we will have a
party and we will have a night ourf I
will invite the English attack he says
me too
he says me too maybe even me three I'm
not going to go for the f4 line we'll
play that will play the typical stuff h5
and everybody's happy
h5 and everybody is happy we've played
this way before and it's not my first
rodeo for sure and these positions get
wild and wacky I'm going to strive for
f4 and just open it up on a practical
level my goal is to just make it wild
and and to open up the position
tactically while the king is stranded
here so this is sort of what I like to
do I've played this approach before
against a grand master of sq LOF who
Valerie of sq luff is actually a regular
player Tiger Tiger something I don't
know what's the best gloves username on
chance comm I don't know if the tell my
head but why it's definitely better here
well I take down the monster that is a
car probably not but this is good for me
and I have to I have to open up Knight
a5 as an idea which after takes takes
even if he takes the 95 I can blow it
open Knight d4 doesn't quite work what
you want to do is you want to create
lines so even taking on e5 and then
playing Bishop to g5 is a strange but
sometimes Samuel Adams decision meaning
a good decision always a good decision
mr. Samuel Adams so the awkwardness here
for black is that the king is stuck in
the center
he plays a5 but I can just chopped him
I'm not too worried about it and I will
just do it
game on like Donkey Kong the position is
completely winning for me right now
completely winning but but it's not over
until it's Rover as you know my idea
behind c3 was twofold prophylaxis to
stop c3 but also Queen c2 to come in
here jingle jangle give me a jingle and
I'll catch you on the jingle he wants to
play Queen a5 check or queen to g6 check
do we care we probably care we don't
want to care but we probably do care I
can play Queen e2 and meet queen check
with moves takes the bishop and I take
on c4 and even there things are weird
but but I'm going to move the king out
first he's playing quickly just as we
knew he would he's playing quickly just
as we knew he would I guess we'll play
rook up one here and maybe strive to get
c5 oh wait a second maybe this was a
mistake by me not totally sure I'm going
to try to get the F file I'm down on
time
I don't like it what am i up here my up
any material I'm up upon I guess so
that's nice well we know what he wants I
can give check and trade into the the
Queen situation but this is not simple
right and my my I guess I'll play King
a1 so that he's not taken with check and
I can try to pick up the h4 pawn but I'm
down on time and I'm already nervous
here as you can tell I would love to
sack the Queen and then made him but
it's not going to work he can block with
the Queen so he moves I guess I'll give
check just for kicks and giggling where
I'm probably winning but not going to be
easy ok let's move over for sheezy
because now the e pawn is overextended
so I can go get it oh I'm losing the b2
pawn as well but can you really play
this way can he really play this way
I think I should be winning here I think
this is Red Rover and I somehow managed
to take the super GM the corn alchemor
down here in the live session so we have
to have a rubber match I guess we have
to have a rubber we will have one more
game where her car will likely abuse me
abuse me for what I just did he's not
happy right now no of course he's been
playing two and a half hours of blitz so
easy for me to do coming in fresh right
coming in as a pinch-hitter all right
well if a car wants it again we will do
it again if he doesn't then we will move
on certainly that was fun I'm not even
sure exactly what happened there oh we
got somebody else the car was taken on
the car was taken on a newbie I don't
blame him mainly because he's getting
spammed with challenges and like I said
this is not the car Oh Danny show we had
fun playing um I was just going to back
up and take a quick look at where that
game went weird for black but I think he
was in trouble the whole time I was
talking about this whole line with that
for and you know black can get in
trouble in those lines because the kings
in the center so I played that position
before
luckily against mr. Abascal off
well here we have a what is going to be
a fun sees a funsies game against an
loser 36 and woo sir and whoa sir I
don't know what that is a new user a new
user I am not very good at reading into
people's usernames I have learned that
about myself from being a part of chess
calm I mispronounce people's usernames
more than anybody a new user 36
obviously but I'm like an Woo's er like
what's wrong with me that's when you
know all right well um this is going to
be an exciting attack like White is
obviously given up the cheap on for this
year so Hikaru is going to bring the
noise if possible he is going to bring
the noise and threats on f7 and east six
are present I wonder if you can just
take on f7 here take stakes and then in
the end he gets Queen takes c6 which you
would think should be a good enough
attack and Carlo says nay says nay I
don't want it yeah maybe the King went
to g7 there you know for Queen f7 check
the King hides and maybe black was
actually okay so d4 of course is strong
too and after it takes takes and the
knight moves black is still in big
trouble here one of the main problems
with the structure again we're back to
one of those symmetrical structures
right except what's going to happen is
when the knight moves White's going to
bring the bishop out and then put a rook
on the D file either by castling long or
not and this pony's going to get kicked
off c4 so positionally very very suspect
structure for black as soon as white can
pry open the D file doesn't Queen if I
check lose a piece I think it does a new
user is now about to be abused sir clip
classic rhyme time rhyme time right
okay everybody at bishop before I can
just play C three
and it is a double attack for people
that are suggesting that so okay a karo
has about 15 minutes left of game time
I'm not sure